it was always my ambition to fly as a
child I thought aircraft were really
exciting and I loved going to the
airport my desire to become an astronaut
is the next logical step
I fly fighter jets I have a degree in
engineering and my crowning ambition
would be to fly to outer space Nicola
Bauman is one of more than 400 women
who've applied to train to become
Germany's first-ever female astronaut
it's been in a saucepan and and it would
be really exciting to be at this cutting
edge of technological possibility the
frontier of human endeavour so for me
there's just no question than anything I
want to go to outer space the fighter
pilot has already gone through the first
round of the selection process there are
only 86 applicants left she's also had
psychological and technical testing it's
important to know all of the procedures
what's the launch procedure how do I
work through checklists
what do I do if things get hectic or
stressful being able to remain calm and
de-stress is important as is being
conscientious I'm always 100% prepared
and I know exactly what to expect half
of all astronauts are military pilots by
profession so they're used to extreme
pressure a fighter jet travels at up to
2,000 kilometres an hour
flying at an altitude of 17 kilometers
Nicola Bauman is a little closer to her
dreams
up to now surgeon Britta Wagner has kept
both feet firmly on the ground but she
too would like to become Germany's first
female astronaut this patient has just
survived a life-threatening operation
Binyam on there and someone who remains
calm in difficult situations who works
in a very precise and structured way and
I like making decisions
I don't shy away from them and I think
that makes me pretty well equipped to go
up into space
some guys go too far all set so I'm the
host again and I'm not an engineer I
didn't study physics and I'm not a
rocket propulsion specialist but I think
I have what it takes to do a good job up
there Britta vogner says that even as a
child she dreamed of going to outer
space she's keen to do research on the
space station what effect of spaceflight
have on people what does it feel like
what does it do to you
someday we'll want to take longer
journeys no one knows what will happen
to our planet so we need to study what
happens to humans in outer space the
film Samia diamond a Maya
an astronaut has to be physically fit
that's also tested during the
application process Nicola Baumann has
to work out every day for her job as a
fighter pilot
well then in Cesare's order in
zero-gravity muscles atrophy every
minute you're up there so you have to
start off with a very good level of
fitness so that you're still in good
shape when you come back oh no no good
to constituents of hardened Commons
family is firmly behind her her mother
and grandmother were pilots too taking
calculated risks is a requirement in her
job as is having an appetite for
adventure the big uns avail I think off
must be incredible the rocket launch
must be amazing putting on your helmet
then slowly climbing into the rocket and
igniting the engine which really has a
lot of thrust and then you're on your
way no roller coaster in the world could
match that her rival dreams of swapping
the operation theater for outer space my
attitude is that when you think you've
hit your limit you can still manage
twice that that's the attitude you need
to get up there and especially to get
back again I can't really imagine how
amazing it must be and will be no I want
to experience it I'll be bowled over I'd
like to make it further than the ISS I'd
like to fly to the moon or to Mars
alternately two women will be selected
for training as astronauts and just one
of them will fly to the ISS in 2020
you